officials coming together to encourage
the community to fill out their census
forms these forms count how many people
live in the US and allocate billions of
dollars in federal funding based on that
information
Kate Houston shows us how local
businesses are getting involved
employees that local businesses like la
Bonita supermarket will be wearing these
green census masks in the hopes that it
will encourage local neighborhoods to
fill out their census form with masks
and hand north Las Vegas councilman and
Mayor Pro Tem
Isaac Barone spoke to the residents of
Ward 1 about the census and why it's
crucial to this community that is
predominantly Latino community is the
kind of community that definitely stands
the most to gain by being fully counted
during a census elected officials
firefighters and business owners join
together to encourage the community to
fill out the 10 question form saying it
takes 10 minutes and the benefits last
10 years they noted that historically
minority communities are under counted
which leads to less funding for
infrastructure schools and social
services the risks are too high we have
to have everybody be confident to help
bridge this gap businesses like
tortillas Incorporated are stepping in
to be a role model in the community
sometimes this little fear as to oh no I
don't want to be counted but it's
important that we're all counted for for
the betterment of our community and our
state the information you provide on the
census form is completely confidential
the forum is available online over the
phone and by mail census takers will
visit homes that have not responded
starting August 11th Kate Houston 8 News
now if you'd like to fill out your
census form online you can go to 2020
census gov the Census Bureau offers
guides in 59 languages including
American sign language as well